I I think YouTube like don't don't be
messing up doing doing PlayStation Time
come
on now he got a
problem
play done yo Co I came in with this song
right
here
care
okay yeah sorry about that guys I don't
know what happened but yeah if you guys
saw it yes I will be streaming Tekken
after this this thing it's on it's on
right all right yeah I see I up up in
there all right cool let me U get the
Tweet out okay here we go they starting
up right now okay we go yeah yeah yeah
playst Studio here we go all right
that's the studio
right go yeah d d on
PC we go so I'm talking about third
party
deals I like the of
it I don't see no hit markers I don't
look better than last show last time I
don't see no hit markers hit markers
so then this is a vertical slice no it's
it's it's not a game so this ain't real
so this ain't so I don't see no points
taken away no nothing this ain't real
this is not representative of what's
really happening this is already see
what T time we you going to get the same
energy that y'all give
us I don't see markers oh man oh that
bug butt didn't look right hey at least
it a at least it ain't in first person
man with with a whip oh
do
like playst Studios and I'm to present
the first state of already got your
man
got where the hell is where do you hide
his
body features including PS5 gameing
check his hands and see if his hands is
bloody play
released to offering new audience to
interact pound of
silver talking about experien yeah he
said it's coming out next week so y'
can get ready to pay we got a pre-order
already exed
gaml God bless shout out to Hollywood
rules Super Chat e for everyone show
thank you hell yeah you know
that people in the the Tekken chats like
this dude put us up over here just to
get some free views I promise you I did
not do that on purpose
the Stella blade what's this what's this
yeah Stella blade here we go here we go
okay okay I better see some hit
[Music]
markers oh let's vertical slice it y'all
living in a lot of cut scenes come on
man go to work this game play brother to
work show the work live captured on PS5
sh up the world the world's most
powerful console shuts off when it
overheats it's so powerful it can't stay
on for more than 2 hours
that guy got a hot 45 minutes the
digital the digital Foundry win
winner takes 10 minutes to fame to
another level K yeah for real
right see see y'all see see
these all right hit markers all right
Next Generation Graphics stop playing
with
yourself
generation this ain't Next Generation
this is this generation stop it bro well
you know what I mean
no I don't all see here you go there you
go 360 Ain you're bending the
truth I heard this don't work on the
digital
version Oh
man heard your portal going to have a
problem you're right it ain't the Game
Pass Edition
he y'all damn sure ain't getting it in
your
service this worth $70 this worth
it is what's your service doing
lately oh great by by the way we have
123 month active users yeah we we got
200 million stop it yeah yeah yeah
salute salute to PC I don't care how you
spell it how you wrap it around your
head 200 I don't care where the money
come from just put it in my bag
200 this is two hours in cutcenes
they'll that was a sacrifice that had to
be
made some yeah it was the disc
drive yo listen Jay this is dopee I
ain't going to front I love the cut
scenes I mean but this is indicative of
the game the game is going to be you
know two hours of cut scenes there we go
come on let's go run down the hallway
this going you you already know King
this is this will be played on your PS5
you no it's going to be played on my
PC
even there you go you got scared
huh I take it I take it as I can get it
look yeah finally right back back there
we go vertical slicing I loved it I love
them they F to give us a release date no
they not like this you'll occasionally
find you get at the next state of
play Hey I ain't going to lie I'll be
mad this is kind of
boring what yeah for real because I
don't I mean the first trailer they
showed look really good but I guess now
they got to tell you what's uh the
systems that's inside they're explaining
yeah they're explaining El you going to
have to do you know what I'm saying this
second this is the second time we seeing
it
right look actual game second this is
the second time we seeing it right will
overall yes but this is the first game
play what we've got first game the first
game play that they all right so so if
it walks off the stage out a date
l
unalan no I don't think so counter
hostile survivors I think so it it looks
good it looks good I think this is
proprietory oh that looks nice Korean
Studio yeah I think it's proprietory and
the mouth that deserves nothing look at
that y out here hating hating what are
you going to do after you defeat the AL
oh you me y you already Y where fing
where where her fingerprints at man
what's up you know more epic you know
turn his
PS5 what would make this interaction
better if there was a show that had
everyone's stuff in it and then one
trailer one of them hyping the next
trailer the next one's hyping hey they
need to do that they need to do that
real talk theofficial name for
members Nintendo Xbox that that would be
dope I can feel the need to make it
happen yo but you know what's funny I
didn't hear none of y'all scream when y
saw this like I will so you you feel
like I feel this a newp this a new
[Music]
IP was Final Fantasy I'm talking about
you didn't scream at all like you wasn't
going
crazy you know I'm cool coming
Collective brother you yeah yeah uhhuh
GT you scaming when you saw a baby step
so stop lying you were screaming when
you saw a baby step so you was about I
ain't going to lie I'mma play that on my
PS5 I mean on my uh my Xbox stop stop
playing J I'm not going to let you run
down that rabbit hole Game Pass Game
Pass oh you calling this coming to Game
Pass N I was on my baby PC game pass Jay
said it
here PS5 exclusive I heard this is only
hours you for what
source that's what youer than Call of
Duty 7 hours y'all paid for it so you
know our financials love your
work see you again next year we don't we
don't we don't mind buying games I could
just see I can see Twitter post right
now articles being wrot according to K&N
News St blade only eight hours long no I
said seven seven
hours you looking for your date come on
give me give give me a release date
April 26
2024 yes after my birthday
yes
blade a banger a banger a triple A
Banger there we go that's
big April they got something yeah they
got something in
April oh D you bad ahead of me I just
now got the be
I'm badhead of me you got you slightly
behind yeah you don't even you didn't
even see the kid talking right the kid
talking now they said April 23rd W this
is for
everybody PS5 we talking about last
night oh yeah look sunic oh yeah yeah
yeah so so far yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know we'll talk after we'll talk oh
man I love the fact that I get to play
this on
Xbox
the build hey hey King King get a good
look because since Xbox is the new Sega
get a good look
yo Jay did you see me I'm Shadow did you
see me I see you brother I came to mess
up your show I see you oh my God I see
you I see you brother you see it in Game
Pass that's a that look good yo that
look good that look good good e for
everyone yo when we going to see a first
party game though I'm waiting this is
this is this is three right three so far
three in and y'all ain't show up
yet y you stupid ah yes
AUM any game Finance by Sony is a first
party exclusive n don't listen to
him he was he was
paid radio type joint what is this
goldinger got this is that uh yeah
this is H this is high five hope
energy hey hey you can't hate on this y'
y'all was hyping up high I can't hate on
this cuz this is for everybody this is
everybody stop that I can't hate on this
we going to get this too you know that
patol thank
you this a I cannot wait forber to come
out after
this now I want Major Nelson to come
out if maj is working for y'all I think
you need to leave and go home oh man now
we got Mikey bar yeah y can have that
dude you you threw him in the bushes too
ke oh I been I threw him I threw him in
the bushes before we got him oh man oh
man develop
for show games is out showing games is
out show gam is out did you play the
demo hey did you play that demo hey
showing gers out I told y'all I show up
this it's going to be a horrible day why
be
a this game here would definitely be
better than on Game Pass Xbox and it'll
be high it'll be higher rated than most
yo yo Jay stop the
cap what's up with your man with the
afro bro you funny it's going to uh dead
day in the in the service play
Playstation servers yeah and it's also
going to be uh one of the PlayStation
Plus free games on
for God thank God is your man with the
booty shorts come on man February 6 is
coming Hollywood rules Super Chat
laughing
about play on PS4 and PS now this is
PlayStation
graphic we'll take it PlayStation
Graphics this is it right here what we
got actual game play games this is on a
PC your PlayStation can't do it so they
had to do it on a PC
son J got J on the is this on Xbox huh
is
this yo listen listen listen I'm glad
that you got something please
Godzilla Andy comes out a did you know
what this is this is sign over let's
go oh my god let's go yo
you Godzilla here Cog will die and Dave
this is a sign brother Godzilla a sign
this is a
sign in the house of the Lord salute no
they did not have the Godzilla godilla
from you God oh what's this
timeout uhoh F Victor all right look at
give it a little little Legend of Legacy
K VI I'mma tell you right now I'm buying
this if it's vampires I'm getting this
interesting I'm buying this cool cool uh
I don't care I've been waiting for a
legacy of Kane game forever I don't it
got Legacy of K energy hey yeah it do I
don't care if it's
not I don't care listen everything I saw
right now was whack compared to this I'm
about this this look crazy your show
been trash until it showed up the music
is
thck oh this this gave the show a for me
hey I'm glad it ain't in first person
thank God cuz y'all can't do
[Music]
that you know how
stutter look look
vlock Studio I gotta find out if it's
coming off for Xbox because you know how
y cap a
lot this next game is a result of
a and marks the return of a horror
franchise that has been with
us yeah Silent Hill Silent Hill Silent
Hill yeah I heard that's for everybody
too here we come here we come baby I
heard that's for everybody too no that
no it's exclusive yeah no no it's not
stop playing can't handle it
messy they took out the portal link you
can play
it man Tomy digital here we go here we
come you got to change your
verbage hey hey y'all already know this
day one I know that for sure anybody
that's old enough to have played Silent
Hill understands what's
up somebody says that V Rising game is
on PC and launched last year oh okay so
they got game pack Guru is saying V
Rising is multiplat but we need
confirmation PC okay so then they take
away the one that I gave it Cherry BL
back down to zero so far ridiculous this
this is going to be this is first person
right this is first person this is first
person third person this is first person
right look this is a whole first person
bro
see you see how when Sony do bangers you
see the quality you get you get to
see y this look like a old corridor from
the 80s bro a man too tight bro pause
photo realistic Graphics that's that's
that's PlayStation baby why the chat say
they got motion sickness y'all messy
y'all so oh man they sent the wrong
message
free to play game free to play what yo
y' got
garbage y got y PID for a free to play
game hey we'll take it we'll take
it take it it's free to play all y to
play
that that's a short
M avilable
now today well there's the high five
Rush Oh God that ain't no high five Rush
St
that God it's free everyone see here you
go King here you go you spoke too soon
King too brother thank you please please
God show me what they've been working on
what they spend their money on cuz their
financials look
horrible okay what all right let's go
Woodside shout out to Sony for actually
making profit they negative 400
million looks very looks very you
billion you spend 100 billion dollars to
come up negative 400 what are we doing
here uh we in first place sir sit
back sit back sit back and watch your
smoke first first now this is now
finally this is finally what I was
looking
for all right so you're back to one
you're back to one like one yeah yeah go
know solent Hill was always a competitor
like to Resident Evil back in the day
mhm I thought it was better than
Resident Evil when it came to telling a
scary
story Resident Evil I'm might have to
get Grace the cosplay as one some of
those
nurses long as she ain't standing on her
hands with her feet cut off we
good here we
go give me a release date
baby I don't think you getting that got
a wish list you we
to they said you got a
wish development
playst yeah yeah just wish for
this this might be the um
Jud joint this is the J VR
game it's a VR game Judith is supposed
to be a VR
game cuz I need to use my VR for
something we're just planted in your
instead of collecting dust in a
garden what would you do to Free
Yourself connect it connect it to your
uh your
Xbox
stupid yeah I'm doing it right now in my
Oculus
I play game pass every day
surprise but I'm
[Applause]
here yes sir you like it or
not thousands of
games
VR hey hey hey yo look at that look at
that first
person look at that it look like first
person you get motion
sickness oh
wow oh look he used a whip he us me real
Arcane SP o that look crazy giv
me yo that look
crazy the way the object Judas fix what
you broke and that ain't in VR Jud
everything is wishless
now development
wait hey hey hey y hey y'all can't say
that cuz think about it y'all whole
showcase you only got one release day
everything else just says it's coming
but your joint says hope at the end your
joint says hope yeah no we actually have
release dates kind of disrespect all the
way up to March and April it says it
says Hope come on
man War keing what do you expect it
ain't freeing Game Pass that's what
happens when Jesse Jackson runs your
department oh man Deep Silver J
deep Sil let's go oh this is metro metro
this Metro this is the VR game oh this
VR oh yeah hey this hey this day we
going talk later day one there we go
who's this it this day one bro yeah it's
VR okay VR PS5 this day one Metro hope
it come out this
year where' King go I'm
worried every time he turns his camera
off I'm like oh God what's about to
happen n n don't be afraid I'm
back he went to check he went to check
his Game Pass list no I went to go check
my VR to make sure it was still
functional game Guru said this is a
great state of wish
listet state of
wish yes coming 20124 coming 202 yes yo
let me find out if I can play it on my
Oculus Pro I can buy pass
you nah the cell phone chip and the
Oculus don't uh don't really man you g
stop that oh here we go this is turned
into a VR show so half of your
crowd half your crowd this is King
there's think about it there's only onep
play VR how Fidel we are thank yeah
listen one out of 10 people have one
I'm so glad I'm so glad Xbox isn't a VR
like Xbox this is one of the reasons I'm
glad Xbox isn't in VR cuz I segments
like this on they show yeah this is for
me and Co for me this is Kingfield me
this me this me y'all don't like VR
games like V we do come on Jay we are in
a minority all right we got I get
it but think about it it if if would
actually delivered was another person on
the screen
multiplayer
multiplayer multiplayer Oh Captain
America
Ship Captain America ship that's that
was L I'm mess with this one yeah yeah
this all might as well just make this
medieval Avengers oh they legendary ta
oh feary the
eight good that's Friday if Friday if
it's not on um whatam call on Oculus
then I I I can get it for them but if it
is I'm I'm going to bypass you wait wait
this cap oh this mon this the um dragon
Dragon Dog yeah 30 frames 30 frames per
second I was doing a video about this
until until your show popped up and then
our financials came out and I had to
roast y'all yeah I do I do the video
today about this I really like Dragon's
Dogma but I thought it was going to be
[Music]
I'm going to be honest because of the
graphics are so
good you can see at least you can see
why they put the the power you know what
I'm saying yeah I know I heard it plays
better on the X hey real talk it it be
some of them games they be looking like
trash and they still be you know that
don't make no sense that don't make no
at least at least show me something
that's
like current jeans Ric and stuff just
look good just day one
yes well my son loves Dragon dog man I
finished
yeah never played a dragon B Dog game I
like the scale of the
bosses though right it it it's I think I
see I think I did see in King's defense
I think I did see no I got the paperwork
on it yeah I got the paperwork on it yo
you ridiculous I got the paperwork
paperwork will yeah th soul that look
good that look good the tree fight that
look hey King King I got a question for
yes every time someone says I got a
question for you now
I'm they they couldn't get 60 frames
with 12 T brother hey hey hey hey jdub
jdub you know what we call this here e
for everybody yo yeah for sure but you
know since y'all do that par
stuff we we go I heard got a easy mode
for you
J
yeah I I heard it's the journalism mode
so uh the journalist at IGN can actually
finish a
game let's let's relax
hey you remember when they came out
talking about they didn't have to be the
game in order to review it you almost
killed me you literally almost killed
me ask J where are the exclusives oh my
there's no exclusives for these dudes
well these are the exclusives look this
is coming to PC reron is exclusive you
about the
PC no this not coming to PC y got to
make money yall not going to buy this so
y got to make money so y going to put it
to PC something I play it gives me like
huge W
Samurai besides up until that point
right there this reminds me of 10y hey
oh my God you see you see it's looking a
lot sharper and better in the graphics
area than the other tra no it don't it
looks like it's stuttering now cuz it
looks like they're playing on the
PlayStation pop going to be real big
Assassin Creed Vibes actually I didn't
like that bush right there I didn't like
that
bush this from the creators of like Neo
you know team
ninja you say sty you can't talk down on
team Ninja's like performance that they
they they deliver they don't make that
they don't they do it quick yeah tenu
maneuver this reminds me of
tenu oh the AI is garbage he even try to
fight
you you got to work on that AI That's J
trying to attack King right now oh no
that was an easy mode that was an easy
mode you see I just killed him right I
just slay it down right no I'm the guy
with the sword staff oh that staff is
crazy
a lie this is looking this is looking a
lot better in the previous
sh yeah we game play yeah we got the
we and he got the
G oh that's
crazy the face he hit him with a six
shooter hit him with a six shooter oh he
said not like that not like this
hey I hope they have a collector edition
for this I
order yeah h i see a lot of
popup that's fine was a little I hope
they clear that
up can't your SSD put Textures in
faster when you going to use that
SSD whenever y'all decide to use the T
flops game play look fun as hell bro
Co going pass this one up n that J I
like the gameplay a
lot oh
godo it look like a bootleg ghost of
shishima n don't do it like that oh
man until ghost of Shima comes up hold
this down you can't say nothing with 90%
of your game so like see of Thieves
brother yo this is this is this is
potato chips when you when you thought
your mom was going to buy you wise
potato chips and she brought
youut your games got to run on a series
s a man this look like oh
man oh SW it from yeah and they got the
old dude fighting yeah potato chips
March
22 your
face
that's I'm definitely going right Corner
that's right around the corner already
B hold on hold on let's see let's
see what did you do just around was
serious until dawn yeah oh yeah the
until dawn remake adct hey
yo hey my daughter I'm going play this
again with my girl my girl really liked
the Cory and I think she's going to love
this game yeah this their best game
their
game a remaster of a game that just came
out last
generation come on come
on unless this is a SE voodo V vo y'
just go down the list of all the games
from might be sequel I don't remember
some of these scenes in the original
this part two this this I want you
to you play your game d why they re
basing it cuz a lot of people ain't buy
it so they got to get a new sucker I'm
okay with got the movie coming out they
got the movie coming out that's why
anytime somebody got a movie coming out
they'll release the the what's I'm just
getting and PC don't duck that PC F duck
that PC f everything captured on a PC
that's fine 100 100% of your games is on
PC now that you know that you're a third
party developer thank you is this
another oh that that's trending too
that's trending too okay finally finally
something new finally something new this
the last game for with Y he not messing
with y'all after this yeah
he got mobile game right yeah yeah go
have fun with what you got G y' got go
deliver another package cuz this is it
for you this the last package K you
better update your Android phone if you
going to play that Kima game don't do o
like that come on come on Jada I just
got the new 24 too so I know yeah man
look at this what's up with her mouth
though her Co mask is
weird she got you you didn't play the
first one y'all didn't play the first
one nope yeah I just I just didn't beat
it I got to beat it okay okay I started
it but I did not get far yeah I got to
get going back I like like everybody I
know that didn't beat it either they
didn't feel like being a FedEx
worker yeah hopefully this is this is
Amazon delivery okay like this like God
look at oh you got it on your hand
you're done son
uhoh that's the mark uhoh you got the
mark of the
piece part one part one was my was my
top top top five best game ever what in
the yo what's going on throat baby spit
out
ships the Mell them hands on her neck is
sick there we go she must be fun I'll
help you get your
bearing this is the ship on the neck
here you can check your
weapons he wish he had that body he back
he back room over here belong to other
members of the crew he said that was a
scan for uh The Walking
Dead that's
prean this is one ship you got here why
they black and white I'm guessing no see
if you played the first game you you you
like I I don't want to oh I find out
that Sony can't do color
scenes sounds like a UCA Big Shot don't
ask I'm going to be C wow that's dope I
like those hands on her face do she got
other hands seriously like those gloves
wearing those extra hands as a scarf
those are those gloves it's crazy sick
yeah if you play the first one you'll
know about like the timefall that hit
hit her hands in as so so you mean I got
to play the first one in order to
understand what's Happening Here the
world together I mean that's probably so
you you asking about the trailer
that's oh my God she got a marry n
puppet on the
shoulder I got to play the first one cuz
I got to know why that guy is there oh
oh Sam even remember him from the first
one what about shotgun that is
crazy that's that's a new that's a new
character do you read me you'll first
need to ACC new character
J yeah but but you'll know why you'll
know why why he's he's around like
that hey but if y'all into it man hey I
have a I have a long discussion about
about the game and explain I got to play
it no people people like it it's on Game
Pass PC right PC game pass you have to
once the game opens up then that's when
you got the
weapons
transportation and everything and that's
when your struggle it makes you struggle
for a few hours to see if you got it to
be able to build it
then see if you tough right days got a
must heart but you'll learn you going
you're going from new basically the East
Coast you need the journey all the way
to the West Coast to rebuild the country
but I'm afraid death stranding is far
from over hey look at that man look at
them Graphics bro like that [__] cut
scene vertical slice J learn vertical
slice actually actually game play don't
act like you don't see y on the PC man
come on PC game pass changed after
you Qui with it man he be quick with I
told you man you can't spar with the
guard mess both of them are and we drew
once things were up and running so your
friends and co-workers all went
characters you got to watch this back
and listen to the
story I like those this is my this is my
this is my type of stuff is yeah that
single player story driven in the corner
by yourself stuff that y do over there
call yeah no internet stuff
support you know we we we out here
playing Power you know what I'm saying y
can't play power world but have fun with
that yeah shout out to power world 7
million shout out to 7 million 7 million
Souls 7 million Souls 7 million players
7 million
Soul you got to look at the
numers million oh what the take the mask
off this this this the new this the new
uh Miss hey yo oh he got a hand on his
what's
F he miss me thing is how I've been
Distributing the fruits of this fine
Factory all over the
continent guns that's incarnation of
Troy Baker's character from look at his
stomach his guts is loose oh yeah
testers is out looks like you decided to
trade in that rope this go why that baby
ain't grow up yet but I suppose even a
poor because it's a connection between
the dead and the living this is
W not not J just pulled you know if you
played the
game let go of me you let go of his man
oh that's right yo why he shaking him up
like that where's the rest of your hey
you know he stole that God War Ragnarok
right yeah he stole his throw baby you
got the baby now keep the baby now let's
see
Louise let see
was it you higs that's
higs that's Troy Baker from the first
game
ah [__] he's back
uh-oh I'm dead oh what is going on I'm
dead yo what is this out of pocket I'm
dead yo is
wild everything
[Music]
you said this is kiss yeah did the did
the baby take over those robots the baby
that's what it sound like he's doing it
sounds like that's what it sound like
that feel
[Music]
bad hey y'all can't lie them Graphics be
on oh gra always let with goddamn thing
about so out there like it's just you
give him credit creative the think of
these kid coima has never made a game
that what's going the on you do find
throw baby's out son pain you nurse he's
out outside the baby is out the box man
in the
dark the baby is out the
box oh
yeah coming expedition was meant to help
you find a strength
outside baby out
the on
the on the beach death stranded on the
beach was a little weird on the be death
strand in the
toilet death stranding on the
plane death stranding in the car death
on the
beach get out of here that contained
Amino essds one's identical instruction
to the kind found in I love
her I'm sorry there are amino acids I
got to I got to beat the first
one to play this one of course how else
did you think that Coral creatures could
emerge from
it that the tower is a sort of
primordial soup this where they had to
wrap them up and burn the bodies right J
or something it was H yeah they got to
do it in amount of time because if not
yeah before they yeah I remember that
part it Expos like a n and Destroy whole
are8 was flaged for disposal and
subsequently incinerated for years and C
long
before nothing else after
this oh yeah with the 40 money Mark okay
game
overaker that's a day I can't wait for
that man everyone yeah Game Pass Game
Pass so what's the end of this year
um and now here the
first Pima Productions
Pima welcome said how you feel that you
know the Xbox money that jacket crazy
together as part of PlayStation
Productions partnership is going to take
us on exciting new adventure one that
I've been encouraging him to
reinvest
SP
joint oh met GE energy
sound another espion action
game not only
do was the mercenary out
here he's
a good for him he said you get in in 30
years um a Newar a new gear type he said
um it'll be on it'll launch new with the
PlayStation app that'll be on
Xbox so why is it we get the AAA games
get how come y'all get the wish list and
we100 billion yo when is when is it
coming
all he doing is selling hope Herman H is
selling
hope got got he got that he got that
Xbox money Herman need to power
up that jacket looking Dusty bust hey
technically kajim Kima is part of Sony
right now basically right hold on there
you go a cell phone game we getting all
the bangers uh-huh uh-huh all right
angry hippie follow the game starts slow
and picks up after a couple hours sounds
like St
M Columbia
Pictures yo they moved your whole
development house to movie
studio before we go I have one one one
final announcement state of Play Return
February 6th with
extens another state of play no it's
just for that there it is oh there I was
wondering where it was going to be at
okay yeah cuz they didn't show enjoyed
the show see you soon so yeah so so
February 6 we'll be back we you showing
up February 6 just to see that damn game
no yes I absolutely they're not gonna
show nothing else but that game that
game is better than any Xbox game ever
created what are you talking about
brother so you
say the hell wrong with you you crazy as
hell no so Gamers say so Gamers say what
Gamers said that
where do you hang out at all Gamers I
mean we know it in the game pass all
right so this game was a hard this this
this state of play was a hard three all
right all right so do you want my answer
was a hard three it was a 10 out of 10
stop lying yourself oh manes of both
gentlemen this was coming he they didn't
have any game pass F there so I'm 10 out
of 10 yo you know what's crazy sus we
got two Next Generation kajima games
this this is this is this is what sucks
for y'all and I really don't like this
and I this is a problem they upped the
service for $40 gave you absolutely
nothing but foam stars and said have a
nice day that's the only game that you s
for your service and this is kind of
pissing me off at this point because
again what is the sense of the service
only to play multiplayer games but
charge you $40 more that's kind of
disgusting and none of y'all guys are
calling it out that's bad so here's the
thing PlayStation Plus is actually
cheaper than game passs not only do you
get goaties inside of the collection but
you actually get games that Gamers
actually want to play and and willing to
pay for okay so that's an opinion but um
again no no it's a fact so let me let me
let me let me give you a fact the fact
that the fact that Microsoft haven't
even updated The Game Pass numbers in
three four five years tells you that I'm
correct okay so I'm just going by the
num let me give you a fact let let me
give you a fact day and date inside Game
Pass uh gives you value and what I
day is a term you know why because we
still haven't really gotten any games
and Game Pass right we three years into
a generation and you really haven't
gotten any value so Ser seriously what
what what games are you gonna buy from
this
show every single one of them
okay y y'all hey y'all got y'all got my
y'all got my uh PSN ID y'all got my game
y'all got all the stuff so they got mine
too I show y'all what I buy and what I
play but um
so one thing about me I
like I like Sony because they deliver
like games that actually show off the
power of the hardware like Kima game you
saw the graphics you saw the you know
the audio there you see the Stellar
blade they actually show you utilizing
the actual system but on the other hand
my Xbox series X will forever be
handicapped by the potato and you'll
never get games like these right because
it's going to be hamstring
by the potato that's just unfortunately
you got the world's most powerful
console with nothing to show it off and
that's just going to be the case Clarity
this show is uh 10 out what you got it
10 out of 10 10 out of 10 10 out of
10 they gave me my kajima they gave me a
release dat for myella my Stella
Gade yeah I mean they gave me everything
I want I got my silent heel I got a
bunch of other stuff so I mean I'm g go
down the line got a wish list you know
I'm do a video and stuff yeah you know
all that stuff you know what the wish
list is right that market so it's going
to tell you whenever the game come out
so you can pre-order it and buy it so
that's what I do you know what I'm
saying y I mean you we don't we don't we
don't need that don't you know why you
know why we don't need a h less we don't
need a hope list cuz we just go in there
and just play we just play that's all we
do we just get in and play every Tuesday
drop up the SE of Thieves and then you
just play We anyway let me ask you this
let me ask you I got one question for
you yes sir did you see the games that
Sony showed right yes I'm a big death
trining fan yes so that game to me is a
system seller Stella
gam a lot a lot of yeah know but a lot
the first one didn't
s the first one didn't sell at all it
didn't sell at all that's why it's in
Game Pass first one what do you mean the
first one didn't sell St strandon didn't
sell it's in Game Pass it's so it's so
it literally sold over 10 million copies
yeah and then went to Game Pass that's
before yeah so sold 10 million yeah it
goes to Game Pass but by your metric
that's by your metrics that's a l so let
me ask you this CA you said power ain't
doing well because they sold 7 million
so by your metrics that's an L they
didn't sell your metric is a l they had
seven million players because it was
free in that's that's see you notice
when they say they scen sold and then
they said 7 million
Xbox they said they said they said sales
okay I'm with you I'm with you Jay come
on let's go you gotta look at it you
know we you know we we keep screenshots
around here that's why we determined we
say nah why did they show the numbers
actual soul but then when it come to
Xbox they revert to players but you know
either way but yeah I give it a 10 out
of 10 um I like like listen I just love
I just love the High Fidelity graphics
and gameplay that's something that Xbox
just can't provide brother okay cool oh
the merits of this show minus Xbox 10
out of 10 okay I got you I God where you
at with this man I think I would give
this overall in eight because we got uh
we got at least what 15 games I think
was total yeah you got 15 games yeah
full uh like gameplay looks at uh few of
these games namely of course the ones
with release dates yeah uh yeah we got
some new announcements but just as in
devel
vment going into this I was expecting uh
a bigger focus on 2024 overall than
right 2024 and looking forward
because for this I wasn't entirely
certain what exactly PlayStation was
going to do outside of Final Fantasy uh
and as disappointing as it is that we
did not get Final Fantasy today I M that
they
said
special yeah I respect that uh and I am
still going to hold on to that demo
prediction for that uh I feel no
doubts yeah it was February 8th right I
think so Fe okay feu okay yeah Hill D
two drop on the eth so so is there like
two games dropp it like next week was it
like H H divers and then
gonna be the uh one of the free games
with play playst no doub what did you
think of um Silent Hill uh godor I do
not do horror so's like I'm good yeah
happy for those who saw it and wanted it
I'm out okay you're good you're good I'm
not doing
it hor games all them what your stand
out if we're
going overall MH I would say rise of
ronin yeah
that it was the combat it was the
traversal it was the destruction physics
that really grabbed me and the fact that
that is going up on the same day as
Dragon's Dogma 2 is a really interesting
competition I think Dragon Dog I repeat
that you're right I forgot I will say
Dragon's Dogma 2o is cross platform so
it probably has the advantage on that
uhh but if I have to choose between the
two I think that rise of
ronin
might you it might keyword might uh do a
bit better than Dragon Dogma
2 absolutely brother I feel like those
who have PlayStations and who are
dedicated to the PlayStation uh
Community uh are receptive of
PlayStation's uh we've seen it with
ghost yeah you know we support our gois
man we support our bangers yeah with
actual with actual money you know what
I'm
saying shout to Gerard worthy2 super oh
man this is messy is that JB or dvon dly
get the table y'all better stop be nice
um what's we got who else we got we got
uh Dean Rivera $ Super Chat death
stranding Sold 5 million copies and had
10 million players the show was a 4 out
of 10 stop the cap all right wait wait
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
So Co you see how people play loose with
the whole players versus Cell thing you
you see how that when when it's
convenient when you talk about just King
and I just had a back and forth right
about po worlds with the whole players
and numbers and all of a sudden now when
it's to try to prove a point then it's
like hey well
Hey listen I'mma let I'mma let y'all
have we'll stick our have players we'll
stick our enough anyway um adct man
where you at with this show what was
your standouts and then overall what did
you uh rate
it ad is in the bushes I think he
stepped away okay no I'm here I'm here
I'm here he got it muted M had solid uh
stuff that I saw there like Ronin looked
really good but as far as like appeals
to me I'd have to give it like a out of
10 cuz like not a lot in the show appeal
to me I don't really care about Kima
games like that they ended with his his
new game and I don't really care about
his new game like that uh Ronin looked
fun I think I'm G to try Ronin but like
that's all like I I'm not even really
I'll try Stella blade but it doesn't
even really to me I was just about to
ask you how are we feeling about Stellar
Blade no one's really talking
about so so I know I know K we we got
you I'm going get
I didn't get adct it didn't move you in
any way graphically it looks okay it
looks fun it's just it's never grabbed
me it just looks like like something I'd
play before like Final Fantasy 7 rebirth
comes out like it doesn't look like
something okay I would play over another
game like I got you good way to put it I
think I agree well yeah because it's all
subjective to the individual it's an
appetizer it's at best it's never been a
main course hold on let me get a couple
that I miss um f uh let's see tx11 you
got 99 cent didn't say anything um just
spart $2 Super Chat I'll give show a one
out of 10 only car about death Strat
come on uh Mr BLT as he should he don't
buy no games he wa for Game Pass yeah Mr
BLT fin Super Chat that honestly was one
of the worst showings I've seen from
Sony in a long time majorly disappointed
I hoped for more wow two out 10 really
interesting hect the Macho Man F $5
Super Chat State of play lived up to its
name Straight Up played in Sony fans
face jdub is defending a two out of 10
show with his Captain Save stop it and
then all right de re okay J said so okay
what we get to 10 million to five so
back to you God as far as the T blade I
mean you how was you feeling about it
yeah like so it seems like a game that I
feel like I would have fun if I was
checking it out but I also wholly agree
with addict's point that it's not a game
that I would commit to over something
else and one thing I will uh ask now
while I'm trying to figure it out for
like later articles how do you get these
games for PlayStation exclusive because
I think hell divers 2 I think foam stars
of course death stranding um
drag r r yeah um the Kima the kajima
games
obviously as far as from a first party
Sony's first party Studios I didn't see
I don't think I should be seeing
anything there but I don't I think I
know you going but they had exclusives
they they yeah yeah they did have a
handful but the more I look at uh the
list that I made during the uh state of
play the more I'm seeing like
multiplatform games like Sonic uh Dave
the diver uh Silent Hill uh
crossplatform that's PS5 PS5 exclusive
okay all right uh and then Dragon sagma
too I don't believe so I think that was
they just got Mar yeah some of the stuff
they had you know when you have the
marketing deal ain't nobody else going
to show it on their stage so you know
you get to advertise yeah that's how I
go that's how I yeah yeah plays best on
you know I'm saying you know what I'm
saying cut the
check cut the
che you know we got
the I
am I am this tweet this tweet that King
shared is what is he doing it's
ridiculous King like you done some funny
stuff but this
particular you know you know I haven't
hit Twitter yet
so you know that's my doain that's why
I'm
quiet he he King back there doing
preemptive strikes before I get on
Twitter listen y'all struck yourself
with the witch list that's alone right
that's here here's the Tweet I'm going
to put it on uh stream real quick this
tweet is hilarious he's he's got like a
Kong in like he's got a Kong in like a
uh yo he's stirring him up I'm
done why you stirring him up like
he that is hilarious that is hilarious
anyway finish your um overall review of
the show add and let these two get back
to VM Messi I got a go suit what you got
oh me for yeah overall I enjoyed it it
was a good show was your stand out was
your number one stand was was the stand
out nothing about the show like screamed
me you know they would show like a
Kingdom Hearts then maybe that would
have they need something that I dying to
play like nothing on the show was
screaming dying like Ronin look cool
but I felt like they showed they had
PlayStation 3
energy some of the games did look a
little outdated in the graphics I would
say silent but that's fine you know I
I'll take that PS PS3 I did the the 360
and Xbox so it don't matter I don't care
what first place you take anything I I
don't care what life ra you want to hold
on
to All I'm going tell y'all is y'all
better get very comfortable with y'all
PCS because of the conso Y the potato
the potato
powerful dud is going away you know what
I'm saying shout out to my man the
dollar man that's your man that's your
somebody give him a life I had I had to
put on the hat because there's a lot of
cap going on over here before before you
start let me just get two super chats
and I Got You sju Sage follow Super Chat
Show was hot garbage five out of 10 only
rise of the Ronin has my attention Sony
isn't delivering and Playstation fans
know it embarrassing ilad SCH slomovic
oh man 30 salute brother show was eight
out of 10 good multiplats solid Hill too
spooky Ronin looks fun but Graphics not
impressive uh justed to his Stella bra
were saving grace alongside Metro uh
through M MP what's MP what am I bugging
um multiplayer I'm assuming yeah through
multiplayer did Metro have multiplayer I
thought it was the other one anyway JB
capping too hard sorry that s sorry okay
King your thoughts on the show standouts
and then overall rating okay so um and
and this is my real rating I'm not going
to sit there and do you know like Jay do
give you a great rating on the show then
go on Twitter and be like it's no I'm
going to give you the real rating of the
show go what's the real my my real
rating of the show is probably like a
four and let me say let me give you
exactly why rise of andona I expected a
whole lot more from Rise of Rona
Graphics definitely didn't look up to
Snuff for me I saw a lot of popping the
graphics didn't look good at all and um
it looked decent you understand it
didn't look like oh my God this is where
our money's at especially if you're
putting it on the day that Dragon dogm 2
comes out we saw Dragon Dog must 2 if
you want to compare the two there's
there's two different classes of games
happening here so whatever happens if
you're into that tent true type of stuff
you it'll sell to you it didn't appeal
to me I'm gonna get dragon Dogman
regardless to what now um Stella
blade it didn't pack a punch but I think
it was more or less the presentation on
how they presented it because the first
time I saw it so so it packed the punch
it had it had that that pop to it so I
think that's maybe a game that I will
have to you know catch on something and
play it and see I will have to see that
game uh and and that was one of my
standouts for the show oh sell okay wow
well it's it's because it's on their
platform this is their joint they're
showing it silent him uh for what they
were showing it looked good but I
thought maybe it needs more development
time that first Silent Hill thing that
they showed I was just like n this is
not it this is not the wave um then I
saw the the vampire game the vampire
game looks good but then come to find
out that's for everybody the problem
with this show is it's a lot of e for
everyone and if I'm keeping the same
energy that everybody keeps with Xbox
when it's e for everyone I take off I
take off minus I got a minus right so
I'm going to minus so again it's like
probably a four because there games
there that I'm interested in well so
this is a bad show to you this is I'm
not say do that sound POS what if that
sound strong if if if I'm including the
multipla games that I'm playing
elsewhere I can see that someplace else
you understand so this is where this is
this is where my minus is coming out
don't look at my four as is a terrible
show it's a good show for Sony guys
right if you only got a Sony PlayStation
and you got a wish list cuz apparently
this is a new thing they got wish listes
and they sit there hoping for stuff to
happen new thing going on I I think
that's cool that they got a checklist
and they can hope that something come
out at some point in time and why you
acting like it's a Kickstarter something
I I think it it sound like it to me like
this is the weirdest thing this is the
first time I've seen it too this and
it's on the wish list like go to the
wish list now like like on the on the
tab of your
PlayStation got wish list
wish they just got they don't we got G
like it's a Gund me it's like check us
out on wish list like what's that that's
some new thing I don't know what that is
you don't know what that is my my
problem with that is y heard y'all heard
it here first wish y' bring y' bringing
new
terminology y'all bringing new
terminology to old people this don't
make no sense we don't like new
terminology for no reason it's not
necessary just say you don't know when
it's coming that's all just don't don't
don't don't bamboozle me you saw the new
hustle
right did you want them to come out like
like Sarah and say these are the games
you gonna be playing she was we see
Sarah we we saw first party so don't
don't talk about old stuff let's talk
about all so check it out so let me give
you the difference let me give you the
difference right let me give you a def
okay coming out in
2024 see our wish list H what do you
want to hear coming out in
2024 or see our wish
list I like the year I like the year I
like the year right could we be honest
here yeah well you know it has both
right you know it has n bro I saw I saw
a lot of wish listing but the the
problem is that that's that's what kind
of soured me because I I didn't like
that taste of that I was like I'm going
put that right there now the je
stranding thing go it kind of pushed me
away because I gotta go play I gotta go
play the old one to get caught up on the
new one but that's how sequels go k no
no no it's cool but the old one didn't
entice me right right it doesn't sound
cool don't sound like you entice that I
mean you seem interested in that one I
would I'm interested in the cutcenes
okay right and then yeah I love the cut
scenes but then he told me this this is
what turn this is what turn this is what
turned me off turned you off when we
hear it you said you got to struggle
couple of hours cuz they got to see if
you worthy to play the game wa wait wait
go back to the stream how dare you say
that after Starfield came out and we
beat Starfield and y' talk about the
game open
up never said
that yo but yo J Jay Jay I never said
that was just talking
about 26 hours but you got to get to
hour number 80 for come on that's them
dudes still stealing ships and acting
stupid all right so that's
that's I'm glad you said this is just
King this is not this is me I'm playing
this is my money I don't care about
nobody
else just saying okay so jbody tell you
okay DAV J all right so Jay coming soon
y'all if somebody tell
you all right you're gonna like the game
but it's gonna beat you up for a coule
couple hours to see if you good for it
like if you worthy yeah you going to
take it as a challenge or you going to
take it as I heard it was boring anyway
it was so many ifs and maybe remember
it's in PC game pass I got a hell of a
powerful PC right here if I ever wanted
to jump in I could did that absolutely
yeah it came there it came there three
years later yeah go ahead I don't care
when it show up we got abely we got a
backlog yeah got back you got to finish
thieves you got to finish
you know you got finish you know you got
to the gois you know you got to finish
you know all your PlayStation remasters
and remakes we got new takes and new
dates you you got you gotta finish it
I'm just saying listen shout out to Neil
drin um what I'm saying is for me
conclusion yes for me Jay this the show
was a four and in all honesty any Xbox
person here that watched it is going to
give it a fall and lower right and I'm
talking about Xbox dudes this is not
none of that stuff made Xbox dudes say
I'mma go out and buy a PlayStation 5 not
one of those games said that King you AB
you know you're absolutely right and I I
I expected that because you got to think
about it right PlayStation has a certain
fan base we used to paying for our
goaties and having the cream of the crop
Choice shout out to my man shout out to
my man David jaffy you know PlayStation
is the roots chis and Xbox game pass and
stuff is the McDonald's we get it we
doing this oh man wait wait wait wait
wait wait so you so you really want to
you don't want to use that anology cuz
you know I'm I'm okay so all right so
check it out me I love David jaffy but
the fact that McDonald's is all around
the world and you can't find rof any
place let's get there let's start there
let do your homework on that let's do
your homework
onil let's let's do our homework on
trillion dollars it different when you
do your homework it different when you
do your homework right sometime you too
busy to have F down andtime that's the
game listen I love to be McDonald I love
to be McDonald because I see what the
bottom line look like and I know the
financials the same like best in life
brother there's nothing wrong with that
every McDonald's you know what I'm
saying when I'm busy so you in there you
in there though right I like my porter
house but you in there though right so
in
conclusion yeah uh I was going to say
what I
feel I'm sorry I just really like Jay y
don't get to do this a lot so y was let
y need a
show it is two different views of the
same lawyers call my lawyers and Y y'all
know we going to make it
happen but you know I just put you up on
that sum Jam screen again right I just
put you up on the Summer Jam screen
again all right let me let me take the
cap off let me take the cap off because
there a lot of cap happen lot of C going
on a lot of C happen today look it was
it was solid it was solid um I think
rise wrote it for me for sure that that
would that really showed out I love the
traversal I love the G the gameplay
actually looked more extensive than I I
thought it was going to be I thought it
I agree with jdub in the sense that it
showed better for me as far as what the
game playay Loop is for felt deten you
VI love the grapp the traversal me and
Gondor is in when he was going from
thing to thing that was my stand out
thing for the show death stranding to
it's death stranding right it's that
crazy kajima he's out of pocket he's
doing what he do graphically you know
what going to look good um surprisingly
the VR game was a stand out for me
whatever that one with the skeletons and
you grab in and they had to multiplayer
the Captain America Legendary tals
Legendary
T I need to find out don't that don't
that come out next week too right is
that PS5 V is that PS VR PS5 only that's
exclusive
oh you know then that get
purchased that gets purchased
surprisingly solid Hill didn't do it for
me I was surprised it it maybe they
would go for like the remaster energy
with the first one I mean probably
that's what it was but I know
graphically didn't do it for me like I I
thought it would be um Judi obviously is
is LaVine you know is you know he's
going to cook um what else we got we go
until dawn I'll be a little disappointed
like all right I like the game I'll
probably I'll probably might still play
it but I am getting a little annoyed
with the remas part Sonic Shadows look
good um what else we what else we miss
to Gondor it was like two more
that Z blade Shadow generations H hellis
I came in on it I like the tone I I felt
it showed better and that's next here's
my thing with the show I thought it was
a Charlotte show my issue though my only
issue is I felt it was very tophe you
got stuff like yo demo now next week
cool my thing coming in shows what was
Sony doing for the second half of this
year like what what are we looking for
because I kind of knew you know the
Final Fantasy which is not there but
it's gonna be on the show and then we
knew um rise of of ronin we knew hell D
for Star we knew that I just want to
know what's the second half so that was
only little disappointment we did get
the the wishi thing was I give K this
the wishi thing was a little weird for
me I never seen that before I don't know
what that is so for me I give it I
probably give it a seven I got to
rewatch it because y'all was too crazy I
get a chance to listen I gave up on
trying to listen yeah I was just like I
might have to rewatch this but I put
subtitles on early yeah you gotta put
this that's what I'm G do going on when
I'm two you gotta put the subtitles on
going on Stella blade interesting looked
good to me I just got to know if I'm
going to be in tune with the gameplay
Loop for some reason I was getting a
recoil Vibe I don't know why but um it
looked good though that's where I'm at
what happened I love I just love you I I
love you because he's the most
diplomatic uh dude he will let you down
easy like he'll go out on the date with
you and he'll sit there and he he the
dude that say you know what we had a
great day but it's not you it's me right
okay like
it's not you it's me and um you did your
best it was great but you know
I yes I I
think I think we cool you know going out
here and there having some I think we
needed more people around maybe that you
know so so I like are you implying that
I cannot say the show is bad you know
what it is and the best part about you
is you bring that even kill you can't
have two of me here both of you you you
know Co is that guy where you know he
gonna grab you by the neck he gonna grab
me by the neck he gonna walk and give us
all pep talk and we'll never have
anything in disagreement at the end two
my
brothers but the best part about it is
me and J having fun with this
we this is old scho but that's all I got
but I let you go I got Gra go ahead
y'all know we don't me and keing don't
get to uh to do this often we we both
busy and so we finally get get together
we have fun we fin to give y'all a show
we fin show out um I'mma tell you about
um the state of play what I really like
um of course I told y'all before you
know when I about that stranding that
that's my top five game of all time that
fits me I tell everybody that my gaming
style may be weird to some people what
what I like they may not like what they
like I may not like that's fine and and
I'm I'm cool with that so obviously
death trining to was all was always on
my uh my top list I'm definitely going
to be Dragon Dogman too that's already
bought I don't have to worry about that
rise Ronin I was actually on the cusp
like I was telling y'all earlier I was
telling Co earlier the the couple of the
first two trailers yeah it didn't really
sell me but now with this trailer they
really cleaned up the graphics and they
really show more the game play so I'm
definitely all in on that um the Metro
Awakening oh my God that's like my top
two of the show uh I beat the the first
met uh the first
metro um on the PC and the PS5 and the
Xbox all three times Judas that was
something new so I can't wait for that
sonen hill to that's day one that's
that's a no-brainer V ryzen bought it on
the PC not really a big fan of it but
hey it's coming to PS5 for those who
like it how does how does it play
because I'm interested if it's like
Legacy of Kane truly
interested I'm gonna be honest oh that
was my I forgot about that game the the
um was it
R so what's the deal with that is it
what what is it what is it I was to be V
hold on one second I just want to know
the details when it's coming out is it
is it exclusive what's the deal with
this it's coming out this okay
so yeah I'm pulling that up right now
let's see Rising listed is
baby survival experience so you'll be
able to build your own castle for this
game you'll be able to like survival
arpg thats like it's going for a
uh I had hour in it hour gameplay in it
I
didn't all right thank you for the
frames on on Dragon you're welcome
you're welcome you're
welcome I'm definitely getting it on a
PS5
PC wait wait Diago said Co you could buy
it on Ally I thought you I never knew
about this game that's crazy okay yeah
yeah yeah that that was a standout for
me I forgot about that yes yeah that it
was really big on PC for like a month or
two
okay wait did this game come out on PSC
already or uh what is it what game V
Rising oh V on PC okay yeah it's been
out on PC for about a year I bought it I
want to say last year Post in the chat
what's going on
post post post with the most my brother
salute salute what's good
F uh of course I'm gonna be on foam
stars on the six I'm I'm I'm gonna be on
that me and the crew you know what I'll
stream that with you J I'll
stream for sure for sure we gonna do we
gonna do it let me get a couple hey we G
run we G we gonna run them Nintendo
dudes away we we we we took your
took his Dr Strange Love 20 Super Chat
Stella blade looks like Chinese
vaporware okay Robert kellet 20 Super
Chat salute loged that in the building
Sonic oh pause
that's Sonic is killing
it shut up Stage One
X ghosta cost 60 million to make and
sold 9.7 million it's a great game but
you got to stop lie y I love ghoster we
have any ghoster slander here
Dr super CH Ronin looks like a better
ghost sorry y GNA stop the slander but
okay I go for roen looks good I ain't
going ain't going to be disect those are
those team ninja people it don't look
like no better ghost man stop that I
will never put it over ghost yet but I
wouldn't do that either those Graphics
is PlayStation 3 let's do it real let's
Doo johnon out Super Chat J Jay I have
game pass but I bought over 20 games
last year one of them was Starfield okay
all right Stitch with the members he
said the show was a hard for Final
Fantasy 7 is not a full game it's just a
piece also how you going to tell people
to wish for games also no one talk
talking about hell divers all right
Stitch feeli strongly yeah nobody care
about hell divers the LI going on the LI
where is Concord I thought it was coming
in 2024 yeah forgot about Concord that's
a good question it didn't it didn't
reach the purge it didn't didn't get
past the purge wait what today is today
is what the the the 29th the 30th
31st okay fair so 31st of January right
Microsoft did they show showing a few
games that's coming this year mostly on
the back end U Sony showing their games
that's coming this year on the front end
okay I like this I like this I like I'm
saying we get another state of play what
next week right it's not like that it's
not like it's not even like that that
state of play is just for rebirth bro
it's just should
be show we got to get our own show you
I'll be reacting to yeah y'all twoo are
out of control so let me finish cuz
y'all are hilarious I love y'all oh
leester c $5 Super Chat um death
stranding isn't on PC game pass anymore
but you could play it on Playstation
extra king or I could do that yeah if I
wanted to that [__] brother sh well I
mean me personally I I
trial of that game I I deined I declined
your offer 15 15 say the best I can do
is 15 the best I can
do we keep it moving I decline your
offer sir I decline your offer we going
to keep it moving nerd and other Legends
I believe on to I don't understand the
kajima obsession all right kajima is out
of the box thinker send Jitsu Sage
follow out Super Chat Sony can serve up
anything and it's Ruth Chris the finite
things in life to sodium it's really day
old microwave Red
Lobster yo see you really got to stop
falling for the the guys that hyped up
battle toes you got comments like from
people
batt batt
do just
saying battle toes was dope stop playing
that that's all I got anything in
conclusion before we got no doubt adct
you got it everybody let's tell
everybody where they let's tell
everybody where we can find everybody
let's start with the the hilarious and
informative always let us know what's
going on
J I will say this real quick I think and
this is just me I think Jay du needs to
be King's co-host on his Friday show
that's just me come
to no cuz that show will be two hours
long yeah you hey hey if if C ain't
going to be
there
we we need structure with those listen
Len and I know how to get together we
work on something even even the even the
last whatever it was only five minutes
it was only five minutes you we back we
kept it you know what I'm saying you
know we a it was only five minutes you
got go back and for we do a state of
something we're going Su Union Address
every month or something yes appreciate
the passion Brothers man bed that s blue
that PlayStation he goes extra extra
hard where can it find people find you
what you got going on
Sir man you guys know where to find me
man on Twitter JW
city6 um I was just talking to uh adct
earlier I think I'm getting back in the
mood man to to start doing some some
videos on back get back on the grind on
the YouTube videos and stuff like every
now and then I get in I get in a little
mood a little stage and then sometime
I'm like I don't feel like I'm going
just stick to my domain my tweets
is all
fire listen listen undefeated man that's
my playround that's my playground anyway
y'all can follow me there man y'all um
listen it's all love it's
all for for those of you guys that go
super hard just know Brothers just know
man Hey listen I got a Xbox man I I play
my man this is this is this is not
serious this [__] tell me like two
months ago he sold his Xbox I don't know
what happened there
but another selling it again you know
what I'm saying oh he got
multiples no doubt brother let us know
when the content Dr would definitely
support appreciate the love thank you
for the New York game awards love man
again all jokes and everything but JB's
a real one I know the chat be in their
feelings with certain things he feel he
reps his his platform but he's a real
one and I always always appreciate your
support brother Rock Lord for a long
time and we we got mad love for you so
it's all good Mr Gondor gaming.net where
can find people find you what you got
going on sir you can find me uh honestly
mostly on threads at this point I I
still have my Twitter account I'm not
really on it anymore but threads is the
main social media I use uh and of course
I'm still writing for the site I'll
still be uh giving my thoughts on
reviews and giving uh any off heads that
might need to be written uh so you can
find me those two places most likely no
doubt salute oh hold on my man an the
ruler is in there proud of you guys I
for Life salute brother seeing you day
one from the Cali sjsu say $2 Super Chat
it's just having fun it's all about
respect exactly don't guys don't take it
serious this is just you know dudes
ripping in the hood that's how we used
to do ranking on each other that's how
it used to go D have fun you already
know what it is Lord addict wa can
people find you what you got going on
sir you can find me on uh Twitter at
Lord addict IOP you can find me on
YouTube at gaming addict unfortunately
after this stream I got to play Tekken 8
uh so yeah I don't go
ITF it direct you guys over there I want
to thank every is that crossplay is it
is it crossplay edit not playing you
crossplay it is crossplay in Tekken
eight so I appreciate coming through and
uh you know me we will be doing the uh
the the state of play on Final Fantasy
next week yeah that's we definitely
build so no I'll be there you know how
okay all right I sit there and say I'm
not going be I'm be there Lord King one
of the messiest but when I have to
rewatch The Stream because of you you
know this yeah yeah I know I know you so
out of
pocket with your analysis of everything
of every game we supposed to we supposed
to I mean it's called and I expected you
know Jay to come through I really wished
he had came through to the Xbox show but
I got him here so I'm glad that he
showed up I really appreciate when you
do show up because it's entertainment
people don't understand uh what YouTube
is you're supposed to entertain and also
be informative you're supposed to have
fun you're supposed to take people mind
off for what's going on so if a lot of
people watched the stream and was like
oh I can't hear the games there is a
state of play that you can watch on the
showny show but you came here to watch
us talk crap and have fun so don't
complain about that uh and that's what
we're going to do uh um XBox Frontline
uh news I don't know if it's going to go
up today because it is late right now
and and I don't need to be going to bed
at No 9 10 10:00 at night uh you know
cutting up a video but I do got some
stuff uh happening for you guys all of
people start I starting to see the coins
that went out to everybody remember we
give out coins every week There's a
winner for every member uh we put it in
raffle boom when I ship it out to you uh
I appreciate everybody that did show up
today the state of play was good if
you're a Sony person this show is
probably like a eight for you if an Xbox
person that looking to get into the sing
ecosystem is probably a four for you but
at the end of the day Gamers is winning
and that's all I want to see is these
two juggernauts came out in the first
month month that's a look that's a great
look said we are out here to fight so
you know one week is one next week is
the next one and we don't know what else
is happening we know Xbox has a crap ton
of games that's coming you know we
didn't even show you the ABK stuff so
whatever they Studio 52 60 Studio
something like that yeah it's crazy yo
cuz that what we did was light
work no wisht list is over here you're
getting what you going to
get anyway shout out to DG do yo I
missed it what games going to Sony from
Xbox nothing did show up the whole slate
the whole s let me go they this gonna
take another
argument anyway everybody enjoy your
enjoy your day say it's all jokes it's
all love salute everybody that pulled up
in the realm today appreciate the Super
Chat and your adding take us
Tekken
eight